Khrie trở biết Anh từng hôm nay,
gọi người sẽ quanh thành phố vào chọn dương trình ở những quản đông khác.
Mạnh đây cũng gửi Anh một số địa mòn mà chí rất địa phương mối biệt.
Khrie trở ở những món ít phổ biến với người nước ngoài như bầu triét,
bố mắm, hù tiêu rê, bánh nì hấp dẫn,
Hau xin chính đổi trải nghiệp. Anh bày tỏ sử ấn tự trước các cách chiếc biến đồ ăn đa dạng vào đúng đáo của Việt Nam.
Cui cho biết, chỉ dương bánh li, người Việt đã có nhiều biến tổ sáng tạo như bánh li bò nế, bò họ, bánh li hấp, đặc biệt mòn bánh li bò họ khiến anh biệt mình đến mức phải tự học để làm tại nhà.
Thích tốt cơ mưa đất còn trải nghiệm cần hết những món Việt mà thực hát nước ngoài thường thấy khó nút, như sâu dương hay các món có mắm.
Cui cũng có trở biết lúc đầu cảm thấy sốc và sự hãy khi anh chính Việt lộ như sâu một thời gian anh quan dần và thế chiếm phang hòn và bèo.
Không chỉ anh như người Việt, Cui còn thành thạo như thảo tắc khi anh như dùng đối, bắt chành, thêm dấu sống và bụn nước lèo, thật chỉ đánh mắm tôn cho sử bò dùi lỗi anh.
Chủ tệ bánh li hấp cô dàng cũng nhận sế khi khách người đất khá sành anh và biết các loại bánh dức phọn gàng, thường cảm ơn khi nhận đồ anh cũng như lúc xa về.
Chủ tệ cũng hành dùng nước mắm rất thử tốn và ý tử không để văn tục đế như nhiều người khác.
Những quán nạn Cui kè anh đều có tuổi đời hơn chục năm, được lứa chủ những khá khó tìm lữ không phải là người địa phương.
Cui còn biết đến món cơm thiệt khó chứng, món bình dân mà theo anh là món đậm đà, hay hòa và ấm cũng như bữa cơm dài điện.
Cui chưa sẻ rằng ởm thực sự không chỉ hút khác nhiều những món lội kiến trong nhà hàng như phở bò, bốn bò hủy, của ở quân thay bún trả mà còn ở những quán nhỏ ở mình trong hệ, khu trợ đêm hay gánh hàng giống bên đường.
Anh cũng không định Việt Nam là thiên đường anh ủy mả anh yêu thiết nhất.